yes Leo if all is going to be around
where it is now around $50 a barrel our
letters estimates show the economy will
decline we'll have a contraction of
about three to four percent which the
new boom deal is what we won't do for
sure the one spur economic growth by
reson inflation issuing more money in my
view how the country's experience with
that has been absolutely obvious
country's attempt to spur economic
growth by increasing inflation by
excessively pumping money into the
system leads to the exact opposite
decision no village episode we really
did increase our gold purchases in 2014
we did it for two reasons first we are
diversifying our foreign currency in
gold reserves into we're solving the
problem of global liquidity they have a
lack of collateral when the central bank
provides rubles to commercial banks a
lot of emerging countries have this
problem that's why we're developing
operations involving gold purchases in
order to provide Robo liquidity we've
got a pretty big share of gold in our
reserves a little less than 12 percent
but we are not the biggest calls folders